cuál es el objetivo del presidente joe
biden al publicar este informe que
revive el caso
muchas gracias por invitarme básicamente
eeuu lo que hace con esto es lanzar
primero un mensaje coherentemente con la
campaña lo que dijo durante su campaña
el presidente bailan en el sentido de
que eeuu vuelve a tomar en cuenta la
cuestión de los derechos humanos en el
mundo
en segundo lugar hace un juego de alguna
manera de equilibrios entre e irán con
el que está tratando de volver a
negociar el regreso de eeuu y que irán
pare su programa nuclear
por el momento civil pero que podría ser
militar pero al mismo tiempo
le da un mensaje a irán de que no va a
ser sólo lo que arabia saudi quiera que
su gran enemigo en la región y arabia
saudí le dice vamos a contar con ustedes
pero también no van a poder ustedes
hacer o por decir así indicarnos cuál es
nuestra política como ocurría durante la
época de trump y es de alguna manera un
tercer mensaje indirecto también así
israel
que en este momento es un aliado no
declarado pero gran aliado de arabia
saudi diciéndole nosotros no vamos a
volver a la era tram o no queremos estar
en la era camps donde hacíamos lo que
ustedes nos dictaba bueno pero una vez
conocido el informe la cia eeuu sancionó
a más de 70 saudíes pero no al príncipe
bin salman siguen mediando intereses
entre ambas naciones entendiendo que
como usted también no lo explicaba área
saudita es un aliado clave en esta
región y perdón si efectivamente estados
unidos cuenta con arabia saudí desde
hace varias décadas es un gran comprador
de armas
es un país que está en ese equilibrio
que se creo que hace varias décadas que
tiene eeuu entre israel egipto arabia
saudí
y en este momento básicamente eeuu
quiere calibrar de calibrar su situación
en la región una región en la que está
perdiendo peso y tiene que ver cómo
conciliar de alguna manera a irán cómo
conciliar a la vida saudí y cómo
considerar también a turquía y a israel
todo esto es un juego muy difícil y en
el que entre y cómo se logra explicar
esto que a la decisión que acaba de
tomar